Pakistani people need democracy that
it's as simple as that we are in 2023
this is the 21st century and Pakistani
people still do not have the right to
choose their representative the only
Power stopping pakistanis to elect their
own government is the Pakistani military
and it is about time that Pakistani
people get the right to choose their
tools their representative and they
decide their future this is why Imran
Khan is right to stand up to the
military and ask for a free and fair
democratic election
Army in Pakistan is a very powerful
institution they have ruled Pakistan for
70 years since Pakistan came into being
Army has started to assert its dominance
in Pakistani political landscape uh and
they have held this key position for a
long time and they're not willing to let
Let It Go they have a lot of influence
they have a lot of power the politicians
are beholding to them
Imran Khan was a democratically elected
leader of the people of Pakistan and he
was removed in a hybrid military coup
where the military helped the Pakistan
then Pakistani opposition toppled the
government of Imran so as a civilian
elected represented of the people he had
every right to stay in power and the
military to double him was wrong
unconstitutional illegal according to
the Pakistani law
for the past like 70 years the Pakistani
civilian structure has been so weak that
whenever the military has decided to do
something they have been able to do it
but now it feels they have someone who
is so strong that he is challenging
their power and that person is Imran
Khan he did not come from this history
of military health
that is why the Pakistani people have
pinned their hopes on him because they
feel that this military and feudal
influence is so in entrenched in
Pakistani politics that there is no easy
way to remove it and it has to be
removed by a book or by Crook and Imran
Khan is probably the least bad option
that we have to get rid of these people
so I don't know if Imam Khan or who is
the face of Pakistani democracy but
Imran Khan right now represents the
hopes of the Pakistani educated middle
class who are fed up of the Pakistani
Elite
[Music]
thank you